star wars battlefront is getting its
outer rim DLC this month but it seems
there is also a free update rolling out
when the expansion lands EA published an
unlisted trailer for the update but if
you manage to track it down you can spot
something interesting an image of Jabba
the Hutt appears along with a message
about new Hut contracts and they seem to
be coming to the game for free Java is
shown holding two new weapons so these
contracts may reward players with guns
when they carry out certain tasks
perfectly fitting for the crime lord
since the outer rim expansion includes a
map featuring Jabba's palace it would
make sense for this mode to roll out
around the same time and the video is
called free game updates so it appears
you won't have to pay for these new HUD
contracts outer rim comes to star wars
battlefront this month and three more
expansions are planned between now and
early 2017 you can get them all
individually or included with the
fifty-dollar season pass when EA
announces more about the paid expansions
or free updates will tell you all about
them on gamespot we're definitely a lot
nicer than the Hutt cartel
haha